Standing at a foreboding 8,848 metres (or
29,029 feet) high, Mount Everest is recognised
as the Earth’s highest mountain.
While Everest isn’t generally considered
to be the most difficult peak to climb (that
honor probably belongs to either Annapurna
in Nepal or K2 on the China/Pakistan border),
it is the most famous and, as such, sees the
most people attempting to scale it each year.
But can anyone just show up and start trekking
up the mountain?
In a word- no.
The first thing you’ll need is to be over
16 on the Nepali side and over 18 on the Tibetan
side.
The second thing you’ll need if you want
to climb Everest is money- a lot of it.
The exact cost of climbing the mountain varies
wildly depending on a number of factors including
from which side of the mountain you want to
start, how many people you’re attempting
to climb with, and what you’re looking for
in terms of support.
A bargain basement cost a non-native could
theoretically get away with would be in the
range of $20,000-$25,000.
A more realistic price tag would be closer
to $40,000-$60,000 from the Nepal side and
about $30,000-$40,000 from Tibet.
This covers things like Sherpa guide fees,
oxygen bottles (which cost about $500-ish
a bottle with a minimum of about 5-6 needed
by most), gear, supplies, travel, performance
enhancing drugs (about two-thirds of climbers
use these according to Dr. Luanne Freer, founder
of the “Everest ER”), etc.
If you really wanted to skimp, you could get
away with not using extra oxygen, but this
isn’t recommended as about 40% of the people
who die in the attempt at climbing Everest
do so trying to do it without oxygen tanks.
This is despite the fact that only about 3%
of all climbers make the attempt without extra
oxygen.
Further, such an attempt will likely result
in, at minimum, a small amount of brain damage.
In contrast to the penny pinchers, if you
want an ultra-premium package from a given
guide-organization, including Sherpas to carry
every little thing, meals prepared for you,
plenty of bandwidth to Skype people back home
as you summit (yes, there is WiFi all the
way up these days), many oxygen bottles stored
along the way, etc. you can pay as much as
$200,000+ per person to climb the mountain
in style.
It should be noted, however, that even with
such a package, you’ll still need to be
in exceptionally good shape and have a great
deal of experience in extreme mountain climbing
if you want to have a realistic chance at
actually making it to the top.
On that note, another thing you’ll need
is a permit to climb Everest, which you can
apply for from either Nepalese or Tibetan
authorities, depending on which side of the
mountain you want to make your attempt on.
As for the cost of these permits, which is
included in the aforementioned price estimates,
up until recently this was largely dependent
on the size of the group you were planning
to climb with.
For instance on the Nepalese side, a group
of seven people could purchase a permit granting
them permission to climb for about $10,000
per person.
In contrast, for a person wanting to buy a
permit just for themselves, this used to cost
a staggering $25,000.
However, the Nepalese government recently
slashed the price to $11,000 in 2015 and ceased
giving any sort of group discount.
This change is meant to discourage people
from traveling in large groups as congestion
at the summit has become a bit of a problem,
with the result occasionally being people
having to abandon their attempt- or try again
the next day if they have the supplies- if
the wait was too long near the top.
(Note- the permit fee for someone from Nepal
is drastically cheaper at only $750 per climber.)
As for the less popular Tibetan side, the
permit there will currently cost you $7,000
per person.
The money from these permits goes to the respective
government of the country you’re climbing
from and is partially spent on maintaining
the various camps on the way to the summit
and paying the staff who work there.
Said staff are also responsible for cleaning
and maintaining at least parts of the mountain,
a job that’s exactly as dangerous as it
sounds, with several Sherpas having been killed
over the years cleaning trash from the mountain’s
higher areas.
One thing that isn’t guaranteed to be collected,
however, is your body if you die too far up.
As such, there are around 200 bodies still
up on the mountain from the near 300 or so
people who’ve died in the attempt at climbing
Everest in the last century.
green_bootsSome of these bodies at one time
or another functioned as something of additional
navigation markers, though not to be fully
relied on given they occasionally disappear
off the path.
For instance, “Green Boots“, an unknown
Indian hiker’s body, marked a certain point
from 1996 to 2014, at which point the body
disappeared, presumably having been tossed
over a cliff or the like in the best burial
possible given the circumstances.
The body of American Francys Arsentiev was
removed from the path in this way in 2007,
nine years after her death.
(More on her exceptionally sad story in the
Bonus Facts below.)
On this note, any group wishing to climb Everest
on the Nepal side also has to pay a $4000
deposit that is only returned if the individual
returns with their trash.
This fee is meant to discourage people just
throwing their garbage onto the mountain as
they trek.
This isn’t just a problem with having to
send people up to collect the garbage, but
also because the mountain is revered as holy
by some Tibetan and Nepali people.
But let’s say that you’re an expert climber
who has all the gear, experience, and know-how
to conquer Everest, but don’t want to pay
for permission to climb it.
What exactly is stopping you from just climbing
it when you please?
Mainly that it’s a really bad idea on several
points.
First, if caught, you will incur a massive
fine and some legal troubles.
A second thing to keep in mind is that the
money from permits, along with paying for
the upkeep of the various camps, also pays
for potential rescue and evacuation teams
who are on standby in the not totally unlikely
event something goes wrong.
Obviously rescue isn’t generally possible
in the higher regions unless someone carries
you down to base camp, but the teams are there
for when an attempt can be made.
However, the Nepalese government note that
it is under no obligation to rescue those
who are trespassing on Everest and, as such,
anyone who gets into distress without getting
a permit faces the very real possibility that
no one will bother to come help them.
Further, given that such a trespasser would
likely be attempting to climb the mountain
with virtually no support (few guides are
willing to take on a non-permitted climber),
it is entirely likely said individual would
get in life-threatening trouble, regardless
of how experienced they are.
A third and decidedly less depressing reason
that climbing Everest without a permit is
a bad idea is that, if you manage to make
it to the top of Everest and then climb back
down without being caught, you won’t be
recognised as having done it.
This may or may not be something you particularly
care about.
Something you will care about, however, is
that there are reports of Sherpas beating
up people they find trying to climb Everest
without a permit.
As one permitted climber who witnessed such
a thing noted,
I did see the permitless chap being ushered
down the hill.
The Tibetan rope fixers were sent up to get
him.
I saw them bringing him down the ropes from
the North Col to [advanced base camp].
It was disgraceful.
They literally kicked him down the ropes.
It was a disgusting example of a pack of bullies
egging each other on and literally beating
him down the hill.
It was absolutely unnecessary as he was offering
no resistance and was scared out of his mind.
The Sherpas are not to be trifled with either.
In one incident in 2013, a couple climbers,
who reportedly treated a Sherpa more than
a little disrespectfully, were nearly killed
by a mob of dozens of Sherpa guides at the
base camp.
They were only saved when other climbers intervened
long enough for the pair to make an exceptionally
dangerous rapid retreat down the mountain.
As one of the climbers stated,
We got kicks and punches and Ueli got a rock
in the face.
One of the Sherpas pulled a knife on Simone,
but he managed to turn and the knife hit his
hip belt….
There was a… period where we all thought
we were going to get stoned to death.
As to why he thought it happened, said climber
stated, “There’s an underlying feeling
among the Sherpas that they’ve been treated
quite badly by Westerners and that clients
don’t have any respect for them.
If you look around at how incredibly luxurious
some base camps are, you can see their point…”
So to sum up: Can just anyone climb to the
highest peak Earth has to offer?
Not really, unless you happen to be an adult
in great shape, have a lot of extra cash to
burn, proper documentation, and feel like
giving the Fates a 2%-3% chance to kill you
within a couple
week period.
The
first
American woman to technically summit Everest
without the aid of oxygen tanks was the aforementioned
Francys Arsentiev in 1998.
However, she is not credited with the accomplishment
because she didn’t make it back down.
When her husband, Sergei, went back alone
to look for her after he noticed she was missing
from base camp after summitting, he encountered
other climbers who stated they’d encountered
his wife near a dangerously slippery rock
face.
They gave her oxygen, but ultimately had to
abandon her when the oxygen ran low.
Sergei was never seen alive again.
Amazingly, despite being exposed to the elements
near the summit all night, and with no extra
oxygen, the next day Francys was found still
alive, lapsing in and out of consciousness,
begging for help.
The climbers who found her the second time
abandoned their summit attempt and tried to
help her.
However, they were ultimately forced to leave
her behind and return to camp as attempts
at carrying her even a matter of metres were
too exhausting in the thin air.
Efforts to contact base camp for help failed.
The mystery in all of this was what happened
to her husband.
The following year, this puzzle was solved
when Sergei’s body was discovered.
Near where his wife’s body lay on the extremely
dangerous slope, he had slipped and fallen
down the mountain to his death.
The pair were survived by their young son.
As mentioned, for the next nine years Francys’
body lay where she died, passed by countless
climbers.
This all changed in 2007 when an expedition,
led by one of those who were forced to abandon
her, set out to “bury” her body.
They were ultimately successful, lowering
her body down off the path where it remains
to this day.
Despite the many deaths that have occurred
on Everest, only around 4% of people who’ve
attempted climbing the mountain have died
in the attempt.
In the last decade, that number has shrunk
to under 2% and the odds are now closer to
1% if you use oxygen tanks.
The reduction in deaths in recent years has
been largely credited to better equipment,
better support as climbing the mountain has
become more commercialized, and improvements
in technology, such as access to the internet
as one makes the ascent, which is particularly
helpful when monitoring the weather and the
like in real time.
In contrast, the mountains Annapurna and K2
boast death rates of about 25% and 23% respectively.